hello there
we all love a good fortnite glitch
sometimes they are game breaking
sometimes they are ridiculous but they
are always amusing the first time you
see them
today's myth chaser episode is dedicated
to the glitches of season seven
from this monsterosity to losing your
head to a floating gun
if you enjoy the video please think
about using code adamaru but a like
would also help me out greatly
enough chit chat let's break fortnite
let's start with my favorite glitch
currently in the game turning your squad
into headless warriors
for this one you shall need two things a
parasite on your noggin
and an io outpost the glitch itself is
extremely easy to pull off
have your partner sit on the turret
which is found at each of the aisle
locations
and simply shoot off that headcrab
remove the parasite
usually the character's head reappears
but while you're sat on a turret that
step is negated
and now you and your troop are headless
i'd low-key by these skins to be honest
just in case you think this is a
cheaters way to avoid headshot damage
i can confirm he does not other players
can still see your head and hit you at
full damage
this is a visual glitch which only works
for people close to you in your vicinity
when you activate it
it's a done past time but it's good it's
good way to bond with your friends
and actually we found something else
take a look what happens to the
gingerbread man
it has the potential to give us this
monstrosity instead
it's pure nightmare fuel what's really
gonna stick in your mind when you try to
sleep later tonight
are those eyes look into them they are
in fact
human lips this dude has three mouths
if you give this a go please let me know
if you find any of the variations of
skins which
are just nightmare fuel like this this
glitch ain't gonna win you any games but
it sure is fun to do with friends
let's take this to another level of
stupidity as we
all know the most glitched item ever
released in fortnite is the inflatable
immediately people learned how to become
completely invisible
and invulnerable too god mode basically
those have since been patched but there
are other glitches which remain
here's a great one to try for this one
you'll need the cow on your back
and a friend to be offered up as tribute
once they've committed sudoku and not
themselves you're going to carry them
but this is the kicker just as you press
the carry button
activate your bull a double jump should
suffice
this will cause a brain fart in the game
and now the person on your back
is somehow bigger i mean look at them
huge this has the potential to be
stacked multiple times to change your
character's size and if you nail this
right
you can create this i have no words for
this
an army of 50-foot squash gremlins is
technically possible
in the game your hitbox is now huge so
don't expect to win many games
and your jumping ability can be totally
broken too
if things go so wrong it's possible to
crash the game completely
gg's all round a few things to note this
glitch is way easier on keyboard and
mouse due to the speed of the button
presses you'll also note that players
will lag and jump around and it's very
common that the glitched player will
begin
falling upwards into the sky so a good
tip is to make a box and revive them in
that the roof should stop them from
floating away
remember when thanos was the biggest guy
in fortnite well look at him now
another ridiculous thing you can do in
giant mode is go for a drive
check it out it's a thing of beauty fyi
if you're struggling to find an
inflatable the best place to grab them
are at the i o locations but you can
also buy one from rick
okay let's take this down a notch with a
glitch which is nice
this season those aliens brought with
them their own biome
anti-gravity blocks of awesomeness what
did you know you could do this
dance around with your squad like you're
starring in et or the new exorcist movie
this is another staggeringly easy glitch
to pull off all you need is a 4x4 light
truck a ute a baki
a pickup truck i hopefully i picked the
right name for the vehicle in your
country
once you bring this thing into the
anti-gravity zone simply jump on the
back
and use a traversal emote we need some
locomotion for this to work
now hold the square button to exit or
whatever button it is on your console or
pc
and now you're flying use jump to propel
yourself around like a ghost
the salsa emote looks probably the best
but you can't beat a levitating chair
remember the epicness that was season
two midas and his cronies choosing a
side between ghost and shadow
that was the season which gave us the
grotto brutus home during the war
since then it's been boarded up and
we've wanted to go back forever
and yeah you know where i'm going with
this there is a glitch to get back
inside the skull rock
for this one you shall need a partner in
crime and an alien ship
oh and a little timing first grab your
mate with the tractor beam and travel
over to the grotto swimming pool
get high and then commit to descending
as quick as possible
and dunking yourself under the water
line just before the buoyancy kicks in
and you're pushed back
up let go of your friend and now
hopefully they should be trapped
underneath the water don't worry you
won't drown here
it's dry land underneath okay so i have
bad news
you are totally stuck here and you can't
get back up no matter what you try
it is possible to shoot whilst under the
water so maybe grab
a cheeky elimination before the storm
inevitably takes you down
the skull mountain is now your tombstone
right now in game the shadow bombs are
totally broken
luckily most game modes have these
vaulted but they are here in buga's new
end game mode
usually throwing one of these down gives
us a short burst of
pseudo invisibility and speed but should
you try this with one of the thicker
characters
like penny thanos brutus this will
happen instead
just like the head glitch earlier on but
this time only for characters with the
sizeable badonkadonk
it will be patched soon so if you'd like
to try this in future
jump into creative right now it's still
there too i don't know why you'd do this
but sure it's something to do staying in
creative is another glitch which is
great with friends
it's possible for your character to
become invisible but your pickaxe will
remain
as does your blueprints your phone your
weapons there's something about a
floating hand cannon coming out of
nowhere and creeping up on you
and blowing your head off dude i love
fortnite to do this you shall need the
phone booth which lets you change your
outfit
and next something like the surfboard or
i prefer the hoverboard
something that makes you go zoom next
simply change your outfit
but be sure to be moving at pace as you
activate the character's skin change
the hoverboard should take you past the
device and cancel
all the operation therefore voiding your
skin and now you've become hollow man
enjoy trolling your friends hang on do
you say trolling or trolling
trolling trolling now whatever
[Music]
next on to something which is less a
glitch and more an
unexpected mechanic and once again it's
thanks to the inflatable item
i first saw squatting dog do this in
which he rolled up five or six stories
and flew into the air before landing and
destroying his prey
so it got me thinking how sticky is that
inflatable
so we set up an erection to the build
limit the theory here is simple when the
jump button is pressed the cow becomes
sticky and can gel to surfaces
in fact every press of the jump button
has a brief millisecond of stickiness to
take advantage of so can we travel
higher than the build limit
in an inflatable well yeah hell yeah one
of our guys went so quickly it's almost
impossible to see where the heck he went
when he flew over the clouds
so yeah not really a glitch but i'm
pretty sure epic didn't intend for this
to happen
here's a brand new glitch from today
which is made for trolling
as i'm saying this the ferrari crossover
began and we were asked to race around
the island following these
icons on the roads well i don't
recommend it but if you so desire
you can take an alien ship and use the
tractor beam
to steal the indicators you'd have to be
one of the most evil people in history
to do this
but i'm sure some of you will relish
this moment just don't tell epic
i said anything finally i thought we had
a game breaking glitch to prevent
headshots
like a bulletproof vest in helmet form
let me explain for this one you will
need a friend
i know that's hard to find a chicken and
a parasite
the parasite needs to be on the chicken
by the way whilst holding the bird aloft
ask your friend to shoot the chicken out
of your hands we found that the sweet
spot is high on the chicken's neck
just before it becomes a parasite if
done correctly the parasite will be left
behind
after the chicken despawns stay still
for a moment
and the parasite will reattach to you
now ask your friend
to shoot it off plot twist the parasite
is now bulletproof
to truly test this we changed teams
because this was battle labs for our
experiments
and this potential great glitch ends
here the glitch
only works around those who are close to
you just like the head glitch from
earlier on
to others the parasite is completely
normal and they can shoot it
and take you out as they please r.i.p
glitch
so there's a bunch of glitches to try
with your friends chances are a team of
sweat will ruin all your fun because
that's battle royale
on screen now are a bunch of legends who
were kind enough to use my code adam
maru over the last few days thank you so
much
as promised look two videos in a week
which is quite a lot for me i know i
need to get better at this
i'm adam you're awesome i'll see you
next time i'll see you on tuesday for
another video
you